okay well correct me if I'm wrong but I
was reading a quote from you that
previously until this movie came up you
weren't particularly interested in
directing a Star Wars film
so what was it beyond you know the
obvious connections that you have to to
those folks that drove it it was a few
things under this particular set of
circumstances it wasn't going to be the
same two-year commitment it was going to
be less than that more a little more you
know more like ten months or so I'm very
involved at imagine entertainment as you
know there are a lot of projects that
I'm working on and so I have to sort of
take a little a little bit of a leave
from from those projects that I care
about a lot in order to take this on so
that's it's a particular kind of
decision but it was the script
it was the Scrat I love the story we
were talking earlier it really surprised
me the way it unfolded in the way the
different ways in which it entertains
last you know I had the opportunity to
just sort of look and see what these
actors were doing with these characters
and I thought it was fantastic for and
and particularly you know I really had a
lot of confidence in in Alden Ehrenreich
bringing this young Han Solo to the
screen in a really exciting way that
they would win fans over yeah I mean
let's talk about that because Alden I I
was I loved him from the moment I saw
him they brought him on stage I liked
Star Wars Celebration or something he
was like so charismatic but he's got to
carry a movie as han Solo and Han Solo
has never had his own you know film so
yeah even Han Solo hasn't cardigans only
him right like you can hear his
important have to carry his own movie so
was there a moment you know on set or
maybe talking to him when you were like
you know what yes you are han Solo well
I I think I felt that or I wouldn't have
I wouldn't have come into the into the
situation and
and and I and Larry Kasdan who this is
the forth of the Star Wars movies that
he's written and he also wrote Raiders
of the Lost Ark mm-hmm and he he had
supreme confidence in in Aldens ability
to pull this off and of course the the
character is so well written as a as a
young Han Solo and it rings very true
because of course you know I'm Jay you
know Larry and Jon Kasim get it yeah and
you know so I really wasn't concerned
about it I was you know I was excited I
also loved he's got a great work ethic I
tell you that's one thing or you never
really know until your the cameras are
rolling and the pressures on and I just
saw the way he would go about exploring
a scene you know sort of finding nuances
whether that's humor whether that's real
honest to drama he I could just tell he
got it and he had the work ethic to
really make it happen
yeah I thought I thought he was so
excellent I know a lot of people put
together this whole web but you've known
George Lucas before Star Wars even
existed it was so cool that you're now
of directing a Lucasfilm every it's
pretty wild it's entirely unlikely and
I'm very grateful but for for this this
turn of events it's you know it's it's
it's been a fun creative experience for
me and again it's not not one I ever
would have anticipated but one I'm
really grateful for and I'm dying to
share it with you know with fans how are
premiered there the other night was was
thrilling because I we've been on such a
deadline that we haven't done test
screenings no we haven't and so so
seeing the movie with an audience
hearing laughs where we hoped there'd be
laughs hearing cheers where we dreamed
you know there might be a cheer here
yeah it was unbelievably gratifying and
a hell of a relief let's both be honest
yeah I mean I don't want to give it I
don't wanna give anything away but there
is a big cheer at one moment and I feel
like what we thought was gonna be maybe
one movie could unfold into many more
there's a lot of open questions that
have come up do you feel like there's
there's a path to make a series of these
films there's there's definitely there's
definitely a path without without a
doubt it's not it's not anyone's
intention as in other words the movie is
not designed as a sort of a pilot or a
jumping-off place for more but you know
in and of itself it's just such it's
it's such a you know a rich corner of
the galaxy or where all of this
criminality is going on and and and
there's opportunities for people to get
in trouble in entertaining ways you know
it's there and then fans are gonna
fans'll to find that it's really going
to be the you know their response and
that's this I think will dictate that I
mean right after the premiere I think a
lot of people are already kind of
talking about that like oh we want more
of these yeah look it's it's it's rich
it's it's it's rich territory and I like
that you know the tone of this movie is
naturally different than the Saga movies
and and yet very organic and very true
to the sort of the spirit of Star Wars
and the range of possibilities with
within the you know the Star Wars galaxy
and and it's I you know I think that
bodes well for for great stories great
creative opportunities for filmmakers
and fans yeah I mean when you can when
you came on board you made it very clear
to us fans that you were a big fan
you're posting McQuarrie inspired stuff
tagging [ __ ] I was like oh my gosh um
would you would you want to come back
and do another Star Wars film whether it
be this or something else I loved it I
you know so I would you know I'm you
know i'm i also love imagine and the
projects that i'm developing there
and and everything that Brian Grazer and
I have going on are you know imagine
entertainment is really going through a
growth spurt right now but but I would
certainly be open to it I made a lot of
friends I already had friends here and I
made more friends working on it
and and I I did really enjoy kind of
rediscovering a you know an aspect of
myself as a director that perhaps I've
thought I'd I'd outgrown or or lost
interest in but but it's that pure
escapism going back to you know splash
or cocoon and at some of those early
early entertainment movies that I really
enjoy the other thing that surprised me
this really surprised me I'm just eager
to work with these characters great
charismatic young cast you know
interesting relationships unlike other
Star Wars kinds of relationships really
impacting the plot moving the characters
but I was I had so much fun doing the
action it was really great yeah
designing it executing it editing loved
it and and it was fun the other night at
the premiere just to feel the excitement
and right in the theater during that
during those as those scenes unspooled
well it was so fun I gotta let you go
but thank rats yeah
you
[Music]